you did it you survived the last four
years and your reward
a shiny new old president today
this country showed the world that there
is no my pillow large enough to smother
our democracy
seriously anyone else feel like they
just lost 280 pounds
democracy prevails but the game
definitely went into overtime
bine talked more about unity than a
marriage counselor who only gets paid if
the couple stays together
on wednesday president joe biden took
the oath of office
and a few hours later late night tv
hosts had
a lot to say about his inauguration
i have to tell you i have zero gloat in
me there is no end zone dance here what
i feel
is enormous relief stephen colbert
kicked off his monologue on the late
show
putting all jokes aside and admitting
that he was unexpectedly emotional about
the whole thing
watching the inauguration today i
recognize just how worried
i've been for my country but we've all
been
too deep in it for the last four years
to truly realize what we were deeply in
it's like we've been on a ship
that's been in a storm for four years
and we just stepped onto dry land
as for seth meyers he described the day
like this
on his show late night so that's what it
feels like when you're not
grinding your teeth i've forgotten he
also seized the moment to take a few
final shots at donald trump
and weighed in on this pick of senator
bernie sanders at the capitol
a pick that swiftly went viral this
picture of him
sitting in his chair by himself like he
was at foot locker waiting for the
salesperson to bring him the next size
up
biden's first act as president should be
to replace every confederate monument in
the country
with this statue of bernie sanders the
plaque can say come
don't come it's a statue who cares then
there was
jimmy fallon it was a bright sunny day
in washington and now we finally have a
president who knows not to
stare directly at the sun the tonight
show host had his own jokes about the
big day
including the ginormous bible that joe
biden was sworn in on
which has been in his family for
generations
that's not a bible you find in a dresser
that is a dresser
even the pope was like that's a little
much yeah
then there was james corden on the late
late show who also pointed out biden's
bible
but look at that that is a historic
moment right there look at that it's not
often you get to see a president of the
united states
take his oath of office on a prop from
one of the pirates of the caribbean
movies
jimmy kimmel had his own special way of
describing his feels for the day
i have to imagine this is what it feels
like when the oncologist calls and tells
you the tumor is benign
during his show jimmy kimmel live the 53
year old comedian
gently poked fun at lady gaga and
jennifer lopez
who both sang at the event two weeks ago
a bunch of dangerous imbeciles with
donald trump flags tried to overthrow
our government today
on that very same spot we had the
national anthem
sung by lady gaga to paraphrase michelle
obama
when they go low we go jlo you